we've got a hot friday coming everybody
whatever you've got
to do this week or this weekend just
make some cool plans hopefully you've
been surviving the heat your ac is
keeping up you're staying hydrated lots
of 80s and some low 90s out there this
morning to start off our day we're going
to heat up very quickly as we get
through the morning hours and the
afternoon a 77 in indian springs that's
not too bad 80 in parum 88 in boulder
city in mesquite 90 in laughlin
down to 100 now at death valley after
hitting the low 120s again yesterday 60
in cedar city there are heat warnings
for lincoln county so cali any you're
included in that all the way down to
phoenix and the mexico border so
everybody's feeling the heat here in the
southwest 111 today just like yesterday
105 is normal and 114 is the record
5 40 was the sunrise and 7 50 for the
sunset let's talk about a little breeze
today out of the southwest the winds
will turn more southerly on saturday and
then once we get into sunday those
breezes will turn more out of the
southeast and we're going to see some
outflow winds from thunderstorms in
arizona sunday and that could actually
trigger some thunderstorms for us as
soon as sunday night and then
better chances right into monday hot
humid hazy heat advisory still all
through now i've come back to the
central plains and the northeast if
you're traveling still going to be very
hot and sticky in a lot of the same
places where they've been suffering with
stifling heat clouds coming up from
arizona the high pressure is dealing us
the heat but these high clouds keep
coming up from arizona and mexico and
we'll have a fair amount of those again
today heat warnings and heat advisories
are all in place until 8 o'clock tonight
lower elevation temperatures 108 to 115
and you can see those excessive heat
warnings they go all the way down to the
mexico border so there's not much relief
anywhere around the desert southwest you
got to go all the way to the beach in
california 88 mount charleston today
112 out at the lake and those winds
they're going to blow a little bit and
maybe rough up the water so please be
safe life jackets water portable shade
111 for us today and look at 109
tomorrow we do drop below 105 on sunday
with that extra humidity and then a
chance of thunderstorms and maybe a
pretty good chance for some rain monday
tuesday slight chances on wednesday i do
like those upper 90s i tell you